Marcus Welby MD and the Dick Cavett show
will not be seen tonight so that we may
bring you live color coverage of the
42nd annual awards of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
you
Oh
Oh
the highlights of Oscar night the
arrival of celebrities first from years
gone by and now tonight here's gig young
nominee for Best Supporting Actor in
they shoot horses don't they here comes
the Duke John Wayne
Paul was instant box-office and the best
actor candidate this year for his
starring role in True Grit
here's an interior the beautiful Dorothy
Chandler
longtime favorite fred macmurray
together with his bride June Hebert and
here is today's epitome of beauty Raquel
Welch
very popular with breasts the world or
the dianne.kennett best supporting
actress candidate for Bob and Carol and
Ted and Alice
followed by Jane Fonda the famous Fonda
acting family also a star they shoot
horses don't they and also an Oscar
nominee tonight
and his fame director Vincente Minnelli
with his daughter Liza Minnelli a
nominee in the best acting category
regardless of the ratings of the motion
pictures referred to tonight all
excerpts have been edited for
presentation on this program
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences
mr. Gregory Peck
good evening and welcome to the 42nd
annual Academy Awards presentation
tonight for the first time Mexico and
Brazil or in the United States and
Canada in viewing our extravaganza live
as it happens the rest of our
international audience estimated at 250
million people in 40 countries must wait
a few hours to see the festivities on
videotape or film for our friends abroad
a word of explanation you'll be seeing
in the next two hours what has become a
major news event the annual recognition
by American film artists and technicians
of excellence in achievement during the
year just past because we're performers
and storytellers we'll be doing our best
to entertain you at the same time and I
think you're about to see the most
star-studded surprise packed Academy's
show of them all here's how the voting
for the awards is done in February
Academy members voted by secret ballot
for five nominees in each category
nominating is done by specialists in
each field for example only
cinematographers may nominate
cinematographers writers writers and so
on and then in March our 3172 members
vote for the finalists again by secret
ballot academy officials do not conduct
the balloting the votes are mailed by
the voters to Price Waterhouse & Company
Certified Public Accountants they're
counted and tabulated there with the
final results known only to one man the
estimable mr. bill Miller who was here
for the 17th time with the envelopes
which will mean so much to so few mr.
Miller
Thank You Gregg here's your certificate
from Price Waterhouse that we again
tabulated the ballots in secret we have
the results in these sealed envelopes
it's my partner mr. Bob Ford and I will
be handing to the presenters tonight
thank you Bill don't go away most of us
these days are asking ourselves and each
other these questions what is the
meaning of the new freedom of the screen
is it something to be feared should the
screen be censored the Academy has
dispatched a man with a camera to
various places to visit with some of the
directors who are making the films
everybody's talking about we ask them
some pertinent questions which elicited
some surprising answers a little later
on during the program we're going to
show you a few excerpts from those
interviews and now I'm pleased to
present to you some very special friends
of the Academy who will be looking after
your interest this evening first miss
Claudia Cardinale
you
miRNA lord
you
Fred Astaire
wrong
Oh Joan
perfect
well
he's worth
father
and John
ladies and gentlemen it's my pleasure to
introduce America's ambassador of
laughter one of Oscars best friends and
I mean friend in the truest sense
they've gone steady for years but never
married he's one of the world's best
loved comedians and a man of true grit
his dressing-room floor is covered with
it here's everybody's friend Bob Hope
late well I I gone I didn't think you'd
show you remember me moisture here
rotten sell a few shirts well I'm
tonight we booked he certainly did a
fine job acting job and True Grit
and I'm happy about that up until then I
thought he was just another pretty face
anyway ladies gentlemen welcome to they
shoot down actors don't they the movie
industry's annual handing out of the
Oscars or is this note at my house
Mission Impossible this is the night the
Oscars separate the men from the boys in
the band
fine turnout for the awards this year
it's so crowded Bob and Carol Ted and
Alice had to sit in the same seat
beautifully gound elegantly coiffured
gathering dedicated to the proposition
that jealousy and envy shall not perish
from the earth as I look around the
theater I've never seen nominees who
were so clean so calm so cool all
waiting for that dramatic moment when
the novocaine wears off I must say it's
a beautiful crowd and everyone who has
anyone in Hollywood is here tonight I
know Liz Taylor's here I saw a Brinks
truck parked outside but this is really
a night to remember it's such a novelty
seeing actors and actresses with their
clothes on
what tension I haven't felt this much
electricity since I backed in the Glen
Campbell's guitar and I want to say
there was some great acting performances
going on in the lobby I just saw a mayor
yardie and governor Reagan shaking hands
and smiling at each other and don't say
anything to Goldie Hawn she thinks this
is just another taping of laugh-in she
saw the Oscars and thought they were the
fickle fingers of fate and come to think
of it if you notice we're less formal up
here this year Gregory pecks tails
didn't get back from the cleaners in
time I don't mind but happened to wear a
tux was quite a joke to Fred Astaire he
wears tails to take out the garbage
anyway I hope your favorite wins tonight
although I know mine won't
you live in a wonderful age today you
can board a jet and Los Angeles sit back
to enjoy the latest movie and by the
time it's over you're in Cuba voting was
complicated somewhat this year by the
postal strike when they finally
delivered the back mail it turned out
the Toby wing got three votes it's been
quite a year for movie did you ever
think you'd see Richard Burton play both
the king and queen
this will go down in history as the
cinema season which proved that crime
doesn't pay but there's a fortune in
adultery incest and homosexuality that's
what we're honoring tonight a sadistic
King a consumptive drifter a male
hustler a schoolteacher drop out in a
one-eyed chair
this is not an Academy Awards it's a
freak out Lane now some great films have
been nominated they shoot horses about
people who dance all night and of a
thousand days is about a king who fights
with his wife all night and Midnight
Cowboy is about a Texan who managed to
keep busy - and was shot in England Z
and Algeria Butch Cassidy the Sundance
Kid in Mexico the only shots in
Hollywood were the ones the actors got
before they left for England Algeria and
Mexico
and there's the sterile cuckoo up until
a few months ago I thought that was the
life of Tiny Tim
then we have mesh the story of the golf
course and the plays directly ahead of
Spiro Agnew
I once bought a roll of paper towels
call Z but I never thought there was a
movie in it but that's the way the
movies are Duke Wayans been around for
years but nominated with him as Jon
Voight whose only motion picture
experience was two years ago when he was
a blood donor for a Vincent Price movie
Elliott Pugh he's one of the new young
stars to come to Hollywood with talent
charm and a total disregard for the
threatening letters I sent him and I
felt so sorry for Dustin Huffman and
Midnight Cowboy he looked so weary and
rundown like he started running around
again with that mrs. Robinson
and how about some of those pictures
today like without a stitch and what do
you say to a naked lady
remember when Hollywood was looking for
new faces
and action movies met westerns
and a movie score refer to the music
x-rated these x-rated movies are really
I think we sale in a few minutes folks
these x-rated movies are really
something one theater manager told me
he's been popping corn for six months
and still hasn't plugged the machine in
I must say if this trend continues they
won't have new stars putting their
footprints in the cement at Grauman's
theater
they'll have sit-ins
picture sure have changed I hear they're
doing a remake of Rebecca of Sunnybrook
farm but in this version guess what
she's growing today High Noon would be a
bottle lunch on a junior high school
nothing nothing is taboo anymore now
when a cowboy rides off into the sunset
on his horse it's just the beginning of
a beautiful friendship
we had how about those Swedish movies
when they shoot outside the bedroom it's
called going on a location
they're putting things on the screen
that the French wouldn't allow on
postcards